MARGARITA ROSARIO:
Everyone needs
a space where they can
feel loved, and protected,
and where they can
actually purify themselves
of ideas about
their work and ideas
about the stressors that may
be overwhelming their life.
When I come into
this space, it is
because I want to feel
safe, and loved, and secure.
Prayer is supposed to be a
time where you completely
stop your day, and you are
willing to purify yourself,
and meditate, and
cleanse yourself
of any thoughts that may
be hindering your ability
to be kind, to be patient,
which, when I'm busy,
I may not want to do
right away because I feel
inclined to finish my work.
Once I come in, I feel
completely at peace
and completely rested.
And it's completely worthwhile.
This room is positioned
on the third floor.
And so you can really
see a lot of campus
just by looking out the window.
But what I especially love
about looking out the window
is the architecture of
the building itself.
And so sometimes, I
sit at the window,
and just think about those small
little things that we usually
take for granted about
the world that we
live in, such as the
fact that we live
in a three-dimensional world,
where there is space, distance,
where there are gaps,
where there are curves.
And we can see all
of those things.
And being able to
look at architecture
and see that, and experience
that, and be thankful for that
is part of the reason why I
come here to meditate and pray.